let's talk about tonight in the return
of my show blue bloods not only is it
the season 10 premiere it is the 200th
episode and Donny here's what I learned
from my time here the cast and crew you
guys really are a family you know your
family too and it takes family to know
mm-hmm the number one thing obviously
that people say is they love the family
dinner scene and that's great for me
because when I first read the script
that's why I want to do the show 10
seasons later Donny's given up secrets
one he helped cast his TV sister to Blue
Bloods wasn't a sure thing we were told
that the show wasn't gonna go to series
on a Friday and by Sunday I was told you
better get to New York the show's going
a series I called Bridget Moynahan when
she said I already turned it down I'm
not gonna do it I begged and pleaded and
made her an offer she couldn't refuse
which was that I'd give her all my
paychecks if we weren't able to shoot in
New York so thank God we shot in New
York to be smarter dawnie Bridget will
and I all relocated to shoot the show I
commute but I pretty much insisted they
shoot at New York of course this isn't
Tom's first hit CBS show
Magnum 163 hours that kind of success
twice in the careers rare you know my
shorts were too short everybody tells
they were shorts like shorts are
supposed to be now shorts are like
pajamas basically he said I wouldn't
understand for Donnie the show has
brought a whole new set of fans used to
be oh my sister loved you in high school
or my sister loved sure I was a huge new
kids fan now it's like oh my god my mom
and dad and my family we all sit down
and watch the show together and my
mother loves Tom Selleck but the real
appreciation comes from the NYPD
themselves I walk by an NYPD officer I
always say thanks for her service but I
also might get a salute that's a big
deal
I had a cop walk up to me recently and
say what are you left or right handed
and I said oh I'm right and there's and
they were like your watch is on the
wrong side it was like they take it
seriously
my wife Jenny hosts New Year's Eve in
Times Square and the first time we went
she was like listen you know all the
cops they they want to take pictures
with me and blah blah blah so please be
patient cuz I'm working hard and I have
to talk to all these people and I said
yeah okay great and every single cop ran
right past her and came up to me and
were like blah blah you do it the best I
couldn't believe it I was so humbled and
honored
[Music]
[Applause]